the sauna help with mycotoxins. So I had a little extra time today, so when people said to the
question, I actually pulled up some articles on this question and the next question. So here's
actually an article that says, you know, heat is a great thing, you know, whether it's a sauna,
either conventional sauna or infrared sauna, it doesn't make any difference. It's the heat
that can really help you detoxify through the skin. That's I would say this forever. Oh, is it
the infrared sauna? That's the best one. That doesn't make any difference. It's the sweating
in the sauna that makes the difference. So whatever will make you sweat, even if you don't need to
have a sauna, if you live down south and it's in the middle of the summer, you go out and garden,
and you sweat like a pig, sweating is going to be a super beneficial way to help you detoxify
mycotoxins. So it helps you detoxify everything. It's going to help you detoxify heavy metals and
everything else, but this study proved that mycotoxins detoxify through the skin. Well, we could do a
study on heavy metals and other toxins that you might find in the toxic detect test. You're going to
detoxify it through your skin if you're sweating like a stuffed pig. So that's the benefit of
a sauna. That's the benefit of going outside and working outside and sweating. It's going to
really help it take pressure off the liver and the kidneys or detoxify your getting rid of stuff.
So very, very beneficial. This question or sorry, the same question, but I pulled up another thing,
this another study on mycotoxins, the show that Okrotoxins are found in human sweat. So the more
you can sweat, just another good study of sweating is beneficial. So the more you can sweat, the more
pressure you can take off your liver, the more pressure you can take off your kidneys, it's extremely
beneficial.